Video'nun sponsor olduğu için 6365'e teşekkür ederiz.
Video'nun sponsor olduğu için teşekkür ederim.
Altyom Designer
Sizi fikirden üretime kadar elektronik üretim sürecinin her detayına sorunsuz bir şekilde bağlayan sezgisel bir arayüzle zahmetsizce PCB tasarımları oluşturun.
Altium 365 platforma sorunsuz bir şekilde entegre olduğundan ek lisans gerektirmeden ekstra kurulum veya yapılandırmaya ihtiyaç duymadan Altium Designer içinden zahmetsizce tasarlayın, paylaşın ve üretin.
Herhangi bir taraycı olaya sahada MDF identify yności中
Ahto partindeиса
105 bu şekilde pois içinde очерede yazan keyfini düşmeyeninizしたsı tüm y masculinity
otexlerden iç hersen gas
Artık aktör part'a güveniyor.
Videonun açıklamalar kısmında bulunan bağlantıları kullanarak bu ücretsiz uygulamaları denemekten ve kullanmaktan çekinmeyin.
Altyazı M.K.